Hi, my name is Sabrina Wallace, and my parents were both part of Space Force in 1969.
Just happen to have pretty crystal in a similar shape.
Now, a lot of people like to say stuff we don't necessarily like to come up and help folks understand things that are difficult to understand because, you know, everybody's busy right now preparing for drone warfare, electromagnetic drone warfare.
We did it in Iraq and then just before and you know, the country's going to war one way or another.
Whether or not it's going to be, you know, our own people or something else, we have a serious learning deficiency in the United States.
Whether or not it was engineered and designed.
I'm going to let other people talk about that.
What I'm going to do today is I'm going to show you exactly what it is that you need to explain to your own children so that we can avoid the mouth style revolution, I'm pretty sure is what they're actually getting mad.
And we're going to do that with education.
So I'm getting started.
We're not.
My name is Sabrina Wallace.
I am a child of an Austin.
And my family members are involved in black projects, seps special access projects.
So I am a BAIER member and my grandfather is Bernard Heinrichs here, and that name is Mr..
He married Helen Harding, and Helen Harding is directly related to Pius Levi.
My father was Steven Garland Davis.
My mother is Lynne Gene Scheer.
They're both secret Central Super.
In 1969, working on Project Silence, I Am a Modified Child due to the Menninger Foundation Experimentation for Human Augmentation.
Now, all that means is that I have scars that most people don't have for John von Neumann architecture.
It's not brain to machine interface.
It's body mass.
That's impossible.
And it sounds What again?
I'm hanging in there.
So here's the wedding list of my parents.
Okay.
Here are the flight manifests out of Edgewood Arsenal for my great uncle.
65/70 Army Chemical, Fort Dietrich.
To where?
Texas.
New York, North Korea.
Just one not good enough.
Eleanor Hall It's still for the three.
I'm probably here was involved with the Mothman Projects and building Vehicles for the Men in Black.
Now, the interface for John von Neumann scars is right under here.
I see one there.
And of course, I'm older now, but that's your heart.
Okay, so this is body machine interface with an underground database called Next the longer, which is IBM.
So in my German class in high school, I spelled it wrong.
Nick fell on the right there.
Okay.
Why does that matter?
Because if people say stuff like this, they had better be able to show you evidence, viable proof, or else I wouldn't listen to them.
Okay, so here's a little more documentation, and then we're going to go ahead and get started with the intellectual discussion.
Okay.
So here's my family and Garland here.
My grandfather, Garland Davis, a World War two Marine.
Fort Meade, NSA.
Mm hmm.
And first, he married Elizabeth Kraft.
But I think something with the DNA didn't take.
So then he married my mother.
Aunt.
Okay.
So you worked for a company that was my parents and my great uncle.
Oh, sorry.
I forgot one thing.
My uncle, my great uncle is where I live.
So he's.
He's always been one of my favorite people.
It's a very kind man.
Oh, come on with.
This time I had everything sitting right on the story.
Okay.
Oh.
So Southern.
So I have a totally different story than my parents.
I was never told anything.
Nothing.
So I grew up and I wanted it.
And they told me nothing existed except what you could see.
And I wanted to know what is all this electromagnetic stuff?
I grew up in the eighties, in the nineties.
I was born in 1979, and if you talked about the aura, everybody shoved you in a corner and demanded you join their group of readers.
And I was always sitting there like, You do realize it's a body part.
And I like, No, you're stupid.
You have to have a religion.
I never realized what I was.
I didn't know why people acted so stupid as in why would you lie about a body part?
And yet my parents were secret squirrels.
That's four levels of law enforcement above anything that civilians see.
And they're the ex.
The secret elite.
What?
It's a secret elite service.
And that's pretty much it.
Once you're there, that's secret law enforcement.
Right now, you've got to go another level up.
Okay, Now I got to go another level up.
They're serious.
Yeah, I get to go another level up.
Right.
So I went ahead and went to work for a company out of Louisville, Kentucky, called High Speed Access.
And this is when they sent me my papers to work for them to see right there.
They just they caught their old adult sweat.
This is the back into space for us.
The actual back end of this country.
I was one of two technicians to wire the state of Wisconsin from dial up to broadband.
So I'm very clear.
L-3 Harris or C 24, all the different ways that we handle with all sorts of intelligence, the NSA's PRISM program, all of it including data grams packets.
Network engineering is not the same as installing a cable modem.
I have to work with the plant technician and the plant engineer.
There's no one hiring a plant in that.
And there was no one hire in that position of me other than the one do.
Yeah, I was 19.
So for international tourism so that as I continue here and people have really had nothing to say to me because I'm exactly where I'm telling you I am.
Full body.
Pardon my dirty foot.
All right, so, Sister.
Let's see.
I asked technical services, professional UW Whitewater monitored campus network, various software packages, including lots of gold in Maps network, vintage HP, open view in brief interactions with snort.
Second shift operations include processing databases using PeopleSoft, eight updated coding routers and switches, work with Visio to create fiber map of campus initiated training For what's simple, of course, it's much a whole state like one little chunk.
When I went to the network operations center, Louisville, or did I want to build me one of those network consultants at Omni Resources in Green Bay.
Trouble OS conflicts, Student trouble, Shock West Conflicts.
The proprietary company developed software, assisted with Cisco Fixed Firewall stuff Program Assistant to Department of Corrections Wales, Wisconsin Installed and implemented In-house Tracking Program Facility Maintenance Department of Ethan Allen School for Boys Develop databases and access and provide a direction for Oracle Implementation Troubleshoot network and desktop issues within the departments and a Big Job.
October 1999 to May 22, Charter Communications maintained an upgrade and taught and troubleshoot ISP network comprised of Cisco three Kong Comm 21 and Bay Networks had five installed racks and had in season.
Colin Cable management responsible for weekly and monthly report some bandwidth and circuit usage test returned cable modems, warranty or redeployment troubles, light coverage area of responsibility for over 12,000 customers installed and maintain Cisco AC 5300 servers for seven separate pools monitored bandwidth in configured Cisco 7200 routers with upgrades for 9000 customers and manage relations between cable operator and technicians in Plainfield, Illinois, while training new staff in the technical and administrative positions in January 2001.
Check out the software listing and that's something permanently disabled in 2004 for being depressed by her own government.
To close the door on this said Are you still telepathic going by projects?
You know, maybe don't you're but by now it's going to be fun.
So where are we going to go from here is we're going to take a walk into the reality of today in 2022.
And first, we're going to have a little lesson from the past.
In my job when I worked at UW Whitewater.
She has a huge magnet underneath her in a fixed low earth orbit satellite above her.
And during the seventies, UW Whitewater had a bunch of software that was laying around for all those underground Nick Furlong, IBM databases and such.
They're underground.
So that's not a maybe that's that's a certainty.
It has to do with cooling more than anything.
So again, as a kid, I'm growing up drawing things like this is they tested brain brain interface for synthetic telepathy.
And people have long since been lied to about that electromagnetic body part.
And now we're in a crisis in our country.
This is from 1993, and this is how the Zigbee Bluetooth layouts go.
This is what they look like.
And that's exactly also how they process in telecommunications.
And I'm going to show all that to me.
But I wish to point out that they were testing on children.
Yeah, that's what our government does.
The parents, my parents, they just hand you over.
That's their job.
It's secret deployment for synchronous.
Nope.
Sorry, folks.
No, I come back to that in just the same.
So this journey for me really started there with being a kid scanner action issues, which is really just me having control of all of my physiology instead of listening to people around me tell me a story telling me how to run me off from being able to just feel my own body.
And growing up from 1979, I have always found it bizarre, unusual, but I didn't know.
I didn't realize that the heart of surveillance was the human biofilms.
And once I did, that was not okay.
And my family made me go away for almost a decade because I wasn't allowed to say anything ever from Perch.
Chris It's the autumn years.
In 2019, I had a run in with an England one called an Ambulance, and on the phone the guy in the ambulance, he said, Get her to the helipad, take her to the lodge, get her to the farm.
Now I'm perfectly just saved by the government.
It was the first time I called an ambulance.
I wasn't prepared for that.
And then I knew the military was watching me.
And then I knew a mistake as set by our Defense Intelligence Agency via my parents.
Not really.
I'm over here working for Charter, but being able to field radar and all these other electromagnetic signals.
That's natural.
The dog reacts the same way I do.
We don't tell people that unless you're in the Marine Corps for situational awareness.
Now, Stingray and dirt Bikes uses that same body part because it's electromagnetic.
And back in 1953, the great uncle, then he brought home a bunch of pictures and electromagnetic drones and 1953 and again, mom and dad in 1969 working on Project Salus, which controls about every molecular state that we've got going on inside of the human body and out.
Now, if you look at cells now, they're going to tell you logistics and motion and basically everything internationally by molecule.
And you go, That's impossible.
That's because you don't know about the nano Internet of Things, the industrial Internet of Things, and that many of these machine interface systems, they were around in 1958.
So why why wouldn't you tell people?
I mean, Edgewood Arsenal.
We're testing on our own soldiers.
Vietnam with my grandfather again.
We've got electromagnetic drones in 1953.
What's going on?
Right.
So I came here to West Virginia and the weirdness with the ambulance and then it continues.
More weirdness, disappearing vehicles.
So going go to the bookstores and they have this question.
Oh, we're planning for the county.
I'm a homeowner, so I went ahead and went to building 60 newest stuff right here in a town of 200 people.
They were take.
Seems weird.
Huh.
So that got me started researching six g lo pin and having come from network engineering and cybersecurity is one of my favorite places because I do math environments and it had to because I had to subnet the back end of space forces to four dot addresses which went on sale in Florida last year from that.
Really interesting.
But I figured that out too.
So anyways, they when you are a network engineer and you're studying for your Cisco certified network associate back in the day you had to actually subnet in binary because we didn't have enough IP addresses.
So yeah, I read binomial math.
It's part of my job previously.
Okay.
And so when it comes to cyber security, this is the kind of stuff in this first part is totally full of just such boring stuff, like the side layers and the internet and stuff like that.
So again, when you have to subnet and you have to insulate your customers and you're beholden to certain thousands of people and they will nail you for being $300,000 a minute of loss, it's charter communications at the time.
Then you have to know what you're doing and you cannot be wrong.
400 grand in a minute.
Yeah, it's kind of pressure you're under in a job like that.
Remember, there's only two people in the whole state that can handle that equipment.
So you don't get to go on vacations.
You basically got to babysit program.
Yeah.
So network security, 60 low personal area network.
And she is going to be using machine to machine meaning no humans involved in a ad hoc vehicle.
Note, for example, here's a striker, here's a drone.
Now, I've got a couple of problems.
First of all, you can't interrupt that drone.
Pentagon statement 3000.09 asserts over 11 years ago and you can find this on CSR.
For example, the the Pentagon in May this year, 2022 said I think that our commanders on the ground need to be able to read the machine learning.
Well, clearly the commander, the husband, especially the commander, did not attend the Artificial Intelligence Symposium on September 10th, 2020.
If the commander would have, he would know that this was no digital nervous system end to end with no humans involved in, I quote, Project Selous.
What did we learn back to product delivery?
Give them the code.
The Salus platform is used for NORTHCOM with upgrades out to vendors.
The game changer is the new neural prototype products are in development and go here.
So what?
New neural prototype Synchro for starters, the G Joint Artificial Intelligence.
What is Fuzing is a fuzing organization focuses on getting products out the door to people who are actually using them.
Then they argued about whether it was going to be Amazon hybridized networking services or digitized, and Microsoft and Amazon were like, or let me have a government contract.
Okay.
Then it got weirder for me.
And as I'm listening, they said data labeling services.
And I'm like, That's a massive database data curation.
And I'm thinking what vendor customers and I wrote, This is the Department of Defense.
So for that you can go over here to the beginning and it says so the team of the Jake I mean the Joint Artificial Intelligence Commission, the role of them is to make A.I.
real and everyone can and should implement artificial intelligence in everything they do.
Customers across the DOD.
What are your customers?
Watch this.
So Contrasting Tools is under the Tradewinds umbrella and project Maven and I quote hot conduits using smart sensors, Biosensors Wireless Working Group 82.1 5.5 Wireless Sensor Networks Specialized Working Group for the International standards of electronics and engineering excuse me, Electronics and electrical engineering.
And Project Maven uses Pathfinder and I to watch you walk around and think inside your house in real time.
And let's a quote MQ nine Tethered to ground project.
That's Department of Defense Directive 3000.09, which asserted again, that's why the commander was cranky because he's like, we can't hear these machines, we can't decode them by their nature and we can't get a signal through.
And I quote over here at the gate, we need to get IBM's system of the Air Force more cohesive with everything else.
We're going to create a digital nervous system end to end.
We need to redo at the DOD how to connect all the IBM's platforms.
What do they control?
Lesbians platforms, Autonomous vehicles.
You mean autonomous drones, tanks, regular Strykers, all sorts of things.
Planes, check.
What about anything else?
Absolutely.
Industrial Internet of Things in those billion that's got self-driving vehicles and it's all allied air.
But you thought that was only for the smart part should look into the RF engineering new way to save the day called the Green Road.
It's not new specialized fiber along the interstate.
When asked could you just use a little bit of light our move the mountainous side that's place monarchs and special access Curtis National Institute of Science and Technology for the government it pay people this is no joke black projects remember I don't really pay 45 grand for a whole toilet seat.
No, they don't.
But you know what?
They do the nasty irises.
For people to have a stack like this, they have to plug in five codes to hide where all the money goes and the resource allocation and the logistics and the shipping, and then the reallocation of special access projects people, and then the reallocation of whoever is in charge of guarding them, tracking them, tracing them, or the Department of Defense to a list for special access projects modification.
It gets out of control and it's all open source and you can read about it and look it up on Google.
So that's our problem here.
So you want to explain to me, what are these biosensors and what are you talking about?
An MQ nine Reaper drone.
It's tethered to my DNA.
What is going on?
And by the way, who are your customers?
Actually.
Cybersecurity.
Yeah.
Artificial Intelligence First symposium.
They told them all the humans are out of the way, so I should put it that one to digital nervous system end to end for these platforms connected with the humans out of the process and into reasoning, enable the current manager directly using data science credit cells and.
Since I was a kid.
Machine Interface Interviews.
Quantum databases.
Manager Correlation.
Now why would they do that?
So the new 60 personal area network is going to use your body to route the data.
And before you think, Oh no, they would tell us this was done in 2005.
That's what the wireless sensor network is.
The biosensors are basically permanent and lifetime since 2005 and since 2005 with Zigbee and Bluetooth, which is what I complained about before when I sent him in, I was just a kid.
Why does Zigbee and Bluetooth and these biosensors look exactly like this?
Because that's how it works.
The international standards for electronics and electrical engineering uses a wide body area network and 82.1 5.6 Electronic standards for wireless working group Wide Body Area Network 82.1 5.6.
And these are the four circles of their technical writing of what they're able to do through your body.
And as always, you know, we should have no more paraplegics and everything.
They can make your hands move.
They monitor your muscle tissue density.
They can make you talk.
They can.
And they do right now.
They monitor all these things wirelessly.
How is that possible If your body needs a wearable or are they using your router or are they using your switch as in or are they using your router or are they using something else?
I wanted to know, so I figured it out.
With the new cybersecurity here with the Stryker and she has to be machine to machine, just like the symposium at the DIA de said.
The problem is, is that autonomy is an empty N9 tethered to your DNA and that DNA generates an electromagnetic body part.
And nobody knows about that.
They call it the aura, they call it all sorts of stuff.
Oh, it's UFOs.
We don't know.
Yes, we do.
Skunkworks, Raytheon.
I just showed you the picture.
The drone people can work for 40 plus years, get paid Really, Really.
Well.
We keep you in the dark.
Cyber security, military, you know, national security.
Oh, it's UFO skunkworks, Raytheon, Lockheed.
Everybody knows this.
They're vendors.
So what's all this stuff about psychic records?
Scientists.
They're inherent in human tissue.
So there was a book I used to have my students read when I taught about this as a kid.
Here it is in 1996.
This book was written.
It's called Integral Psychology.
And inside you're going to find what I just said about telepathy, empathy, precognition, all of it.
It's assigned to certain areas of the brain.
So are those sensor networks down to the nanoscale?
Then they put it on a proprietary software when they have to write for Zigbee and Bluetooth for those permanent lifelong biosensors and, you know, 2.1, 5.4, they are permanently affixed to your body where.
From the radio frequency syncs.
There are two of them.
They're going to pull all the electromagnetic energy, including the potentiation of minerals, out of your biochemical bloodstream and transduced them because your electromagnetic field here that you thought was worthless didn't exist, and everyone made fun of you.
It actually transducers anything electromagnetically.
Now we use synthetic radio.
This is a software defined radio.
Synthetic telepathy, just to agitate your skin.
A little electromagnetically transduced in and out, using your own body parts.
So how do you think they're up?
Computer data?
The same way.
The biosensors are literal magnets.
They're fixed and adjusted with voltage.
How to Wireless Working Group ADA 2.15.5.
And that's your personal area network.
These are your personal area network as well.
My time, as you can see right here, the six G Maupin may or may not have a body area network for security routing purposes.
They're routing their data through your tissue and I quote an exchange digital information using the electrical conductivity of the human body as a data network body area network.
So why don't we need a brain chip?
Because you've been wireless for 6000 years.
Chinese medicine, the meridians, chakras, those are nodal points on your body, electro electromagnetic telemetry.
So the permanent biosensors were rolled out to everybody up here in 82.1, 5.4, and they had to be permanent for Zigbee and Bluetooth, and that is what provides them.
And then the wireless working group meter 2.1, 5.5 takes care of all the different types of networks, then collects certain sensors from only certain bodies, open shortest path, first routing protocols or security driven reasons.
But they also, when they create them with Zigbee and Bluetooth, they have to select muscle tissue type.
Since 2008, they have to select heat so you don't smell death.
And so they were working on that until 2011, in 2013.
And now they have about 13 different routing protocols, but only about three of them are built to protect you from the information you incur by routing data through your body, which pulls minerals from your red blood cells to do so.
Now, it's a very minor level zero notice until too many companies are pulling on those statistics mathematically at the same time.
And here's what that looks like.
So right here in our little example, you may also want to note that these two are of six each have five nodes sticking out of them, have been labeled right here and one, two, three, four, five.
So for every little dot, you got five more and they're all electromagnetically accessible through the cloud commercially with Zigbee and Bluetooth, which again is actually, you know, 2.1, 5.4, because if they weren't, they couldn't sell Zigbee and Bluetooth in the wall.
They couldn't have used the Alexa that way.
All these different things communicate with these sensor networks, and they're all driven by artificial intelligence databases and they're all interlocked.
So if you are wireless and you're on the same wireless working group as your phone, which is actually, you know, 2.1.
So in a wide personal area network, they're routing their data through you.
Since 2005 and I can write an app for it and then I can play with you like this because these here are accessible since 2005.
You think people haven't had enough time to buy synthetic telepathy, wearables?
It's all written.
And if you didn't know how writing an app is not hard and the GitHub style it up with something called structured query language, hey, what's ask you out to the backend of Microsoft, Apache and WordPress and ask you all, Hi, this the Hadoop of style.
So these people in the nineties before this was rolled out in 2005, and by these people I mean my parents secret squirrel, secret law enforcement all this stuff for again for who again Space Force since 1969 signals intelligence etc..
Okay so they have something called brain brain interface, a synthetic telepathy and it's frequency driven peer to peer.
Yeah.
And they put on a helmet at their desk and they can cruise right through human tissue.
Again, these things are monitored in real time.
Tell us if that wasn't bad enough.
They also have you by all the collection databases that you see listed here.
So the TV, all of your senses, stuff, radar, Doppler and then the dirt boxes fly above your head and they communicate with the stingray software, which is written for individual sheriff's departments, depending on what type of databases they want to subscribe to.
So what you end up with, it's here's three bodies walking along the road.
There's two bodies in a house.
These bodies are now being utilized by that same driver because their bodies just happen to have the best security in machine.
To machine only uses those criteria and they're listed if you want to read through the machine, learning to watch the order.
And then the key to the separation of how many times they hit the node, how long they wait .06 second delay.
And it's the same in cybersecurity for everything.
Hello.
Goodbye.
Intermittent.
Wait, stay.
And if you know anything about data hacking with packets for real and not just the software defined enterprise cloud stuff, meaning and mainly using software, I mean like the hardware side, they pull the whole packet apart down to the physical Mac address layer of your body.
That's the problem we're in.
That's why we're down to the wire here.
They're wired into their bone marrow.
And the way that Cisco McCann powers everything around them in the smart grid is when you walk, when you dance, and when you move.
And that's another portion you can read about in eight, 2.1, 5.5 and wide body area networks 802.15.6.
So again, the problem we run into is that when you have three bodies walking down the road, these two are now firing tons of signals that told you every node is five more.
Now, all these sensors are going crazy.
This person here, the machine selects this person here, the DNA, your DNA, your body.
That is what creates the secure signal that the drone is using is propagating your DNA.
And that is exactly how it works.
So in order to stop this drone from firing anything, you have to stop your DNA from propagating.
Why would they do that?
So one last time.
If you're unlucky enough and somebody gets hit with a bioweapon.
This is electrical transduction over the open wireless working group of wide body area networks.
So it doesn't matter what you believe in.
And it never did.
They did all that right here.
You were both psychic.
And then when they transduced humans and they do actual testing, which is wireless tissue engineering and wireless total piezoelectric control, neural mitigation for behavioral modulation.
We brain damage.
You mean very subtle nanoscale areas of your brain to keep your behavior under control.
Then we send you to people and tell you cognitive behavioral therapy will help you in cougar needs artificial intelligence programing.
We know if you say it over and over again, you're going to do it.
So why wouldn't they fix your epigenetic environment?
Because they're not interested in that.
Or they would have told people about this stuff a long time ago.
They were studying transport and they would test people for this for their science of abilities into bioinformatics and genomics.
Once your body could no longer transduced these electromagnetic signals, this unnatural, it's too much power in the bloodstream, in the bone, and your vascular system going.
Eventually it weakens the veins, the arteries, the skin, and then you're in trouble.
So are you pretending to get lost in the woods?
Did you go underground?
I'm kidding.
So this is what they did.
Nobody's told the truth.
Stingray and law enforcement was all wrapped up in 1972.
So I was used by the police chief with my brain or, scuse me, my machine body interface at the time, because they still had to have a study table with nano lipid or hydrogel so that they could go through and show it on a monitor.
That's what all those guards are.
So now everybody's quiet since 2005 and available commercially.
And again, the new standard for cyber security is a wide body area network which may or may not be involved in a personal area network which may or may not involve your iPad and all the rest of it.
The cyber security right here, February 2022, for the six time open digital I.D.
routing and the digital ideas made of your phone.
That's right.
Frequency and residence of your what?
Your DNA generated electromagnetic wirelessly accessible since 2005 commercially body part.
They never let you know about your doctor won't admit to it.
You'll learn.
We'll talk about it.
And if you try.
But make fun of you.
Why?
Don't you want total control and humans and have them on remotes to make them do whatever you want?
No free will, no ability to think.
I told you.
Neural mitigation with subtle.
What again?
Behavior modification.
One more time.
Vital signs, respiration.
Easy.
ACG monitoring monitor glucose hearing aid.
What are the non-medical uses of what you're putting through your bone?
Because when they do, your red blood cells have to operate to the routing and they will magnetically pull those excuse me, those minerals hard on my shoulder, right out of your bloodstream.
Well, video streaming data, file transfer sports, 3D, video, forgotten things, monitor.
And then one more time you will be allowed to do three things entertainment applications, PR and gaming and social networking.
Starting to see how the metaverse electroceuticals the Internet of Things, Internet of bodies, the cyber Internet of Things.
It's all tied together inside your brain there, here.
So when I tried to tell people how I am from blood projects and you got to understand this body part and if you don't start working with it, you start figuring it out.
This is drone warfare You're going to wait on you don't nobody.
So what you have to do is understand that the only thing you have right now is physiology first, which is to admit it's the body part.
They hit it for total human enslavement and they have it.
This is an amazing it's all done in the police department, in the sheriff's departments.
Like I said, they're finished in 1972, being able to talk to each other with synthetic telepathy and a bunch of little kids.
And then when we were teenagers, here came the rest of it with the 2013 was when they actually rolled out brain chip interface.
Professionally, people still don't know that.
They still think you need an actual chip in your brain.
You don't.
You just go buy a nano antenna with the right frequency for the wide body area network.
It's like a hundred bucks and then you buy a $200 synthetic telepathy generating wearable that just goes inside of your cranial nerves to subtly and allows you to hear all the signals around you that are projecting on these networks.
These networks are connected to everything on the Internet of Things, industrial Internet of things, cyber nano internet of bodies, and make fun of you Internet bodies to them.
Like, as if you don't know the specificity, then you have to because then they said, Oh, but it's only in hospitals.
And I'm like, No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
That's just silly is I mean, I mean, this is an engineer design.
Why would you leave it only in the hospital?
I mean, it wouldn't even function that way.
It's completely wireless, satellite, inclusive.
So at that drone chooses your DNA because that MQ nine has been tethered to you.
Remember I just pointed this out and I'm going to go said MQ nine.
September ten, 2020.
Artificial Intelligence Pentagon MQ nine Tethered to ground Project Maven Project Pathfinder with object Detection.
That's right.
In a cognitive body area, networks are becoming that confused because they use something called an adversarial network and they attack you.
Because they're watching.
You think with those comments cognitive for cognitive radar watching you think in real time.
And it shows up in a little tiny outfit and they click a button.
They got a heart attack and a stroke or anything they want any molecule, any state we face state, it's all available to them since 2005.
Oh, bare minimum.
My parents had this procedure, so it's in 1969.
Every molecule on the planet, everywhere.
So how did we get here?
How did all this get in place?
No mental accountability, no mendacity, nothing.
We just let them get away with it first.
They were subtly electrocuting.
A lot of people got fibromyalgia, but nobody knew.
I said, a tumor is you have a tumor, but we can't physically find it.
It's just your brain is acting like it then pseudo seizure.
So, gosh, we don't know why you're having so many seizures then.
Lupus, Lou Gehrig's disease, an autoimmune 80% of your immune system is in that invisible body part in 40 to 60% of your endocrine system.
So that's why all the hormones can never get under control.
You keep screwing with the electrical transduction of the basic cell structure of your largest organ.
Come on, people.
And then they don't.
Diseases.
Oh, I don't know what that is.
They do.
The World Health Organization admitted to that Cancer is not my story to tell, which is why I leave it open.
So a lot of people already figured this out with cancer.
They're like, Wait, I'm sick that now you want me to take chemo?
Like what?
And yeah, so not Mr.
Endo, but now we're all the way down here into sudden adult death syndrome.
Gee, we don't know why.
And when they move around too much and have oxygen transduced in the red blood cells, too much happens to be too much radar from Amazon shipping services.
There's too much regard from just regular companies for security.
Maybe it's just a regular company that's dredging geology or the top of a rock set or whatever the now it's pulling from your body to scan the area.
Again, it's just part of a wireless sensor working group up here of the ATO, 2.1, 5.5 and point four.
But now it's using your body because you are in the, you know, 2.1, 5.6.
And for our purposes, for this, instead of the Stryker, that's a satellite.
She needs your body in eight or 2.1, 5.6.
Those are permanent lifetime sensors since 2005 commercially available.
And the DOD is selling through the database access to you using our same census and Doppler and heat and light and where you live and who you talk to.
Which is why the whole reason that led me here was when I realized that my county, whoever it is that I live near, my little town of 200, is looking through my bloodstream.
That's still open and that's freaked me out.
I followed the link and I did the reading so nationwide and again, this is 2022 February for digital.
I did jumping a geofencing catching people so they can't leave their geofence.
But didn't anybody tell you you were wireless because they don't want to give you the remote control to your own body.
So what are you going to do about it when the radar comes at you and she's ready with her DNA to end you?
Because that's the lethal autonomous weapons statement I kept reading out of that college textbook.
Yeah.
So you can't hear it, right?
Your body won't hear it come in, whether it's drone or trans duct.
Yet that's a light on my channel, An Odyssey.
It's full of electromagnetic warfare survivors, people like myself that this stuff was tested on and then implemented at the industrial governance scale for the Defense Intelligence Agency, the NRO, or whoever.
We got to understand now is that you you're out of time because they're going to war.
And they've been at this since 2005.
And again, my family was in in 1969.
So here on my channel, I teach biofilm practice, I teach offensive and defense.
Defensive is great because then you're opening yourself around inside your own field and you're learning how to actually listen and breathe.
But offensive biofilm practice came last week, and I have at least suggest that you observe it before you try it and before you do anything you're familiar with your body again and correct all the things they taught you wrong so that they could access you at the remote, take away your immune system, because what's going to happen is the plasma charges.
And if you watch that 2030 talks about this, those plasma charges.
Yeah, that's true.
Electromagnetic body part, you're going to feel it either way.
But if you have knowledge ahead of time, you're not going to be afraid and you're going to be better prepared to observe your environment topologically epigenetically and really understand the people who are complicit in all this stuff that's really evil.
They will tell you your biofilms start real or they won't talk about it.
And then if they're involved in about two thirds, it's the purposes of this country is involved.
They'll just pretend it doesn't matter and that, oh, it can't affect me.
I believe this is the center of the revolution.
They're trying on our country because our youth biohazard this stuff and they know how easy it is to purchase that 400 bucks and have telepathy and affect people in Hollywood.
They've been doing it for a long time.
Well, now they're taking it a step further with tissue engineering trends, magnification.
And I said to people, they're going to turn bottom of your arm into fish.
But then they're like, Oh, we're not in together.
And so now it's here.
There are doctors out there that are offering to change people's DNA and alter them into animal states, etc..
Yeah, we know that's what everyday it plays a part in.
Okay, So step one, you've got to get honest about your physiology.
You have an invisible body part and everybody knows except you.
That's a problem.
Why?
Because it's your body that's important.
The whole body instantly.
Now project that field.
Steamer sports.
That was whole.
Let's take a look at the bias that actually looks like it's electromagnetic energy, isn't it?
You hear that drones coming.
You're going to feel it.
Your body naturally does.
Algore seems for the birds.
All that stuff notes ley lines.
Military has been using them a long time.
Why didn't you know?
Why aren't you allowed to know?
Step one It's your body part.
Step two get right with God.
Prayer for people who are like one.
Jesus.
Okay, well, whatever you want.
Physiology.
First.
It's a body part and get right with God.
Prayer for people to represent all forms of love.
Then practice religions, whatever.
Okay, Notice are separated.
That whatever you believe in is the duty that loves you.
Knowing that there's something greater out there than yourself.
That's private.
That's personal.
Your soul, sovereign being in your skin.
Super.
Okay.
So for anyone to have some magnets with voltage adjustment then handed it up to law enforcement and secret surveillance and no doctors, no nothing.
For how many years?
Then all of a sudden, after the project says, Listen, I'm going, Oh my God, we're in so much trouble.
Cats, dogs and goldfish.
And that's when I got really mouthy this year in April.
And I said, The bubble bitch, here's your veins and arteries.
They're fine.
Just fine now.
They're not put on much effort, that is.
But so much effort.
This is.
Watch carefully and then go view what the biosphere looks like when it fully expects.
Twisted.
Doomed.
You're not pulling the trigger.
You will be damn lucky if you can even get to my door.
And by the way, precognition, again, the book I showed you, Spiders eat with it.
So why are you still pretending that you are not in their Defense Intelligence Agency?
Pentagon databases with every dream that you have and that your precognition is also watched because in your tissue.
That's why spiders eat with it.
Same way with Algore.
It's all natural and everybody's always like, Oh, I love being in nature.
Why all these wires and things?
And pretty soon they're going to go away.
And most people didn't know that we had all this scrub atomic plasma and all the rest of it.
We had it in the 1800s and they took it away for 150 years so they could sell you back your immune system and lock you up.
Now they have we don't have your bio fuel and the upcoming electromagnetic warfare.
You will not survive.
It's that simple.
So your chances now and you don't have much time.
1953.
What do you think they got now?
You.
And then.